foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the daily mirrors associate editor Kevin
McGuire and the columnist for the
article Ali Mirage so a very good
evening to both of you and just to say
that they will both be with us from now
until just before midnight so before we
talk to them let's take a quick look at
what's making some of the front pages
and the mirror leads with President
zelenski's surprise visit to the UK and
his plea for the government to give
Ukraine practical Military Support
likewise The Daily Telegraph quotes him
saying give us wings for freedom
and this same headline is on tomorrow's
times
while the eye says the government is
effectively looking to threaten Vladimir
Putin with the possibility of British
Firepower
the Metro combines the names of our two
countries to suggest Unity
thanks for the tea now give me your jets
as the headline on the front of the Sun
as it references president zielinski's
address in Westminster Hall today
the express looks at how former prime
minister Boris Johnson is Keen for the
UK to send Ukraine all our Jets
and the same story makes the front of
the Daily Mail
now the star isn't happy that some MPS
want a 162 000 pound payment if they get
voted out
and the Ft has a story concerning the
Indian conglomerate adani Enterprises
and just a reminder that by scanning the
QR code that you can see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us
so let's bring in now Kevin McGuire and
Ali Mirage and take you through some of
those uh pages and uh Kevin let's kick
off with your paper with the mirror here
at the headline give us your Wings of
Freedom a paraphrasing president
zielinski's message in the surprise
visit to the UK
no absolutely and I planned four weeks
but kept uh secret and then it was
announced just after eight o'clock this
morning only his second trip outside of
Ukraine since the invasion a year ago
this month then that was to to the US
but it was a very powerful speech he was
warmly welcomed of course he didn't just
come to give facts as he always does he
makes a request and this time it is for
for planes and the government has ruled
it out before saying it isn't practical
uh now it's going to look at it but talk
in terms of a long-term solution which
suggested some time off because I
suppose that the the raf's got about 30
f-35s about 100 eurify at typhoons the
cost of 100 million pound each it's
probably not just protecting those
assets if you're gonna if you're gonna
donate them they require ground Crews an
incredible uh maintenance to keep them
keep them flying so it it is pretty
tricky it's not just like uh sending a
car over to to you crane it is very
complex but Rishi soon actually gonna
have to make a decision now he couldn't
just say no so he says nothing's off the
table but it doesn't yet feel as if the
Jets are actually on the table well yes
that's interesting isn't it Ali and
let's take a look at the front page of
the eye shall we because they say UK
warns Putin we may send fighter jets to
protect Ukraine but as Kevin was was
implying there we didn't get a very
clear answer did we from the Prime
Minister nothing's off the table but
it's not clear whether or not those Jets
will go from the UK
well I know what uh Rishi Sun at the
Prime Minister following this visit from
president zielinski has done it he's
asked Ben Wallace the defense secretary
to investigate the issue now and come up
with a a potential plan to indeed send
Jets I think there is a lot of pressure
now zielinski gave a very very emotive
well-delivered uh impassioned speech as
he does I mean he he's very good at uh
PR in the media and getting his message
across he did the same thing a few weeks
ago in Congress and got tanks on the
back of it and now we're talking about
fighter jets I mean it's interesting
because if you go back six months there
was a real reluctance on the part of
NATO and Western Nations to provide any
offensive or be seen to provide
offensive equipment at all because they
didn't want to be seen to be uh giving
soccer to the Russians to come back and
say well you're getting involved in the
war well we've come a long way since
then it was only a few weeks ago that we
were agonizing about whether to give
tanks now we're considering whether to
give uh planes so we we really have
traveled a huge uh distance on that on
that Journey the question I've still got
is what does success look like and that
is a question that no one yet has
answered now president zielinski may
have his own view which is to push the
uh Russians completely out of Crimea and
out of all uh areas of the donbath
that's his View and he's entitled to do
that uh the question is where are NATO
on this at the moment they've left it to
zielinski to determine what uh he is
comfortable with and what success looks
like for him but we are providing
weapons here so I do think that the West
also has to have a view on how far it
wants to go this you're dealing with a
nuclear armed power here uh this is very
very uh tricky and dangerous and of
course we should support the ukrainians
but we are now in the de facto war with
everything being provided apart from
boots on the ground now some people say
we should provide boots on the ground
that's always been resisted by NATO
because they didn't want direct
confrontation with Russia but
effectively you are in de facto creeping
commitment here and I think that that's
something that has to be considered the
other thing that said is under pressure
on is funding for the armed services
only this week a lot of senior military
personnel said he needs to step up in
the budget and backfill a lot of stuff
that's gone to Ukraine and step up
funding well yes some questioning
whether we have enough fighter jets
anyway to provide military experts also
suggesting that if you're going to
provide tanks you need the fighter jets
to provide cover for them or they're not
going to be fully effective and Kevin
before we move on from the eye there's a
photograph of Rishi sunak with President
zielinski there on the on the front page
how important do you think this visit is
for Rishi sunak I mean we heard
president zielinski in that rather
impressive address uh in Westminster
Hall
um acknowledging the work that Boris
Johnson had done but do you think Rishi
sunak is pleased to be seen to be
bonding if you like with the Ukrainian
leader is he coming out of Boris
Johnson's Shadow on this issue
I know I think absolutely uh president
zielinski one of the few world leaders
the shorter also than uh
um but now no absolutely now zelenski is
not stupid he's very clever he plays the
game brilliantly and he will know the
shots are now called by sunak Boris
Johnson can exert pressure he can go on
his trips he can now call for fighter
planes you can you can even propose that
Ukraine join NATO didn't propose that
when he was prime minister and actually
the European Union which he wanted
Britain out because it was undemocratic
but he thinks it's okay for Ukraine he
could do all that but the but the power
is Now with uh
as the Prime Minister and uh and he's
just very clever he's very clever at his
politics zelensky here there's many
Western countries not all around the
world of course because China or India
South Africa or of not condemned The
Invasion but you know certainly in in
the Western Europe a lot of support for
landscape and he knows how to press the
buttons to get that military military
aid but I still think Jet's way off just
listening to the to the words there's no
way sooner could say no but he hasn't
said yes interesting yes and and Ali if
we turn to the front page of the sun
um they focus on the meeting with the
King today now give me your jets as
their headline but I'm quite interested
by the fact that in the top right hand
corner you've got
um the appeal that the sun has launched
for the earthquake victims and we'll
come on to talk about that do you think
president zielinski is is mindful of the
fact that people have given a lot
towards Ukraine he might be worried
about compassion fatigue and now there's
a very big crisis in turkey and Syria as
well and he wants to make sure that his
message still cuts through
of course and I think it was a very
important visit that he made today and
he does know how to get his message
across very effectively his PR is second
to none and he gave a very powerful
speech in Westminster Hall earlier in
the day and then he went to see The King
and I think the king gave him a very
warm reception uh King Charles is uh
naturally uh very empathetic and
sympathetic to the cause of the
Ukrainian people rightly so and I think
that was a real warmth between the two
and I think also presidents elect he
spoke very um with great affection about
uh King Charles when he had previously
met him as well so I think it was a big
moment and zelenski is now also meeting
Olaf Schultz and uh president macron
this evening in France ahead of meetings
with EU leaders later this week so it's
not just weapons that he wants but the
bigger picture is he's also pressing for
Rapid extension into the EU within two
years which is really interesting and it
will be also interesting to see how
turkey reacts to that being a NATO
country as zelensky also wants to be in
NATO how turkey reacts to the fact that
if um uh the the exception of uh
Ukrainian to the EU is accelerated how
turkey will feel about that because
they've been courted for years uh and it
has to be seen to be a Level Playing
Field so a lot of political Dynamics yet
to play out here yes indeed and and we
we touched on the earthquake there and
let's let's turn now to some of the
coverage in the papers um Kevin in the
mirror tomorrow a double page spread
that you've picked out
um the headline get me out of here and
this extraordinary picture of a little
girl Mariam who has been trapped under a
collapsed building but protecting her
little brother with her arm and really
moving photograph it's those those
personal very you know
there's personal stories that really cut
through in this appalling Pauling
tragedy
yeah and that's her brother there
stroking his hair and they were they
were free to after 36 hours they were in
Northern Syria because a lot of the the
coverages uh focused on on Turkey but it
is it's across the uh the two countries
and the the stories are heartbreaking
we've seen pictures of babies being
taken out of the rubble alive the
newborn baby born in the ruble for the
baby's children killed uh that that
picture of the man in the orange jacket
holding the hand you could just see the
arm and the Hand of his dead daughter
who was still trapped it just you know
just really hurts you when you see that
and of course uh or just watching your
coverage earlier on the the period when
you can rescue people that's coming to
come into an end if they've been trapped
and they haven't got it and they you
know they're not protected from the cold
nothing to drink nothing to eat uh it's
absolutely
um terrible and yeah compassion fatigue
there's been no sign of it yet if you
know people can't afford to donate they
shouldn't feel any any shame and if they
can good for them
well yes and and Ali there's so many
aspects to this story aren't there the
the obviously horrendous personal
tragedies is the main thing but already
questions being asked about whether
enough's being done in terms of Aid
getting there in time and uh in turkey
and in Syria and whether or not the
scale of Destruction could have been
avoided there are so many issues that
this throws up
it's been absolutely horrific and uh so
many people have died the estimates now
at 12 000 the World Health Organization
saying it could go up to twenty thousand
absolutely appalling uh the biggest
tragedy since uh 1999 potentially were
about I think 18 000 died back then uh
and it is it is heartwarming at least to
see some people being pulled out but
that's going to become increasingly
difficult now because as well as uh so
many hours have elapsed since this
earthquake took place you also have a
very cold environment now minus three
degrees temperatures out there so it's
going to be increasingly difficult now
and it's really really horrific and the
politics of it are also quite difficult
you're right to mention that aid needs
to get there as quickly as possible but
you've also got to mention the the
political backdrop to this is going to
be very difficult for president erdogan
he's got elections coming up in May he's
got 50 inflation before this happened
and it needs to be seen to actually
respond to this huge uh actual disaster
and that's going to be very very tricky
for him given the the political and
economic backdrop he faces well that's
right and he's dismissed the criticism
of the operation hasn't he he said that
the the state was doing his job he said
it's not possible to prepare for
disasters of this magnitude although he
did admit that there have been some
difficulties with the initial response
but Kevin also lots of questions in
Syria as well because you know there are
there are areas that the government
controls there's this area where lots of
different groups control all around the
border and only one border crossing
currently open
no absolutely it's a it's a fractured
broken uh state after 12 years of
conflict uh you know a southern dictator
is uh still there in Damascus didn't
control the entire entire career but it
makes it a lot harder to get uh to get
Aid in because the UK official Aid
budget was uh slashed by about 4 billion
uh Rishi sulak when he was Chancellor
there's no deadline uh timetable yet to
to restore that cut
um so Britain like many countries has
pledged uh what what is really a
relatively small uh small amount but
yeah there's a question certainly for
Assad murder one in in in Turkey but at
the end of the day you know Turks and
syrians they're people who are dying and
then it they need our help and it kind
of cut across and forget the politics
about it it's what can we do
yes indeed and um and something
obviously that the aid needs to get
there quickly doesn't it and the urgency
is uh very apparent
um let's move on and see if we can get
in a couple of other stories that are
featuring in the papers as well although
those two obviously dominate the papers
tomorrow
um but let's turn to the front page of
the telegraph now because um their
second story here politically correct in
inverted commas prevent focus on far
right over islamist at Terror Ali this
is this is a focus this is a review that
was done into the prevent program isn't
it
the other two should say one is this is
William shawcross who's done the review
Into the prevent program which was
designed to uh tackle uh islamist
extremism that's where it started uh a
number of years ago it then moved on its
remit to also tackle far-right extremism
uh and also the point that he's making
in this report is that instead of uh if
it does not focus sufficiently on
non-violent extremism and what it does
is it treats people who go down the road
of non-violent extremism as victims
rather than as potential terrorists and
that's a serious problem as someone who
um went to University in the mid 1990s
and saw a bunch of islamist extremist
groups trying to infiltrate my
University or the London School of
economics and not succeeding because we
tell them to go packing uh they were
spouting bile and hatred back then and
this nonsense has been continuing for
for decades now and the the issue is
back then they weren't they weren't
going around and getting on a conveyor
belt to then commit terrorist atrocities
but had plenty of them we've had a
Manchester Arena bombing 7-7 London
Bridge attacks so the problem here is
it's not just the people who go and pick
up knives or machetes or whatever they
want to do to go and terrorize people
it's also people around who give sucker
to this kind of ideological demagogic
nonsense that these people spout and
that needs to be nipped in the bud